it's disgusting you know what i mean um
but this is this is what this is who we
are you know what i mean this is
this is what's going on you know uh and
it's been incited
and uh people can't be surprised by
what's happening because it's been kind
of provoked for a long time
and it's here now and it's not being met
with the same
outrage and the same anger as as other
things that have
other protests and things that have
happened you know
over the last recent months um i'm
praying for everyone involved you know
for safety
you know i i believe they said some
people were shot injured
so you know praying for the best outcome
possible in those situations but uh
you know like i said it's been provoked
for a while
you know so uh just hoping we can get
peace at some point
[Music]
it was dwayne brown seahawks tackle
addressing the events of january 6
2021 one of those dates that will join a
short list of
not good dates in american history don't
know how else to put it we'll look back
on january 6 2021
in horror and disbelief for years to
come fortunately the death toll was
far lower than it could have been some
would say far lower than it
should have been that's the core of the
concern that's going to be articulated
by nfl players and other athletes
now and in the coming days and weeks
when you see the images yesterday of an
insurrection and that's exactly what it
was it was an insurrection against the
government of the united states
you see the capitol building sworn
swarmed excuse me on
one of the most important days for what
happens
inside the certification of a
presidential election
if those protesters slash
insurrectionist
slashed terrorists had been anything
other than white
what would have happened yesterday it's
a fair question that's been raised over
and over again
they would have been arrested killed or
somewhere in between
if it had been black or brown protesters
terrorists insurrectionists
and it ultimately was an insurrection it
was and it was incited by the highest
level of our government and we need to
call it what it is this is no longer
politics
this is an attack on our country that
was instigated from
within and it built over time
and we saw it coming we knew it was
coming we knew anyone was
imprisoned six months eight months i
mean yes go ahead
sorry ever since ever since the election
results
were proclaimed by multiple media
outlets that waited too long to do it
because i think they knew deep down what
the reaction was going to be by the
person who lost
this plan was put in place and the
ultimate hail mary was
yesterday's march to save america that's
what the sign
said as the president of our united
states was speaking
to the mob that ultimately was unleashed
on the capitol
this is no longer about politics this is
about accountability
the person who holds the office of
president of the united states is a
clear and present danger to our national
security
twitter shut him down the bad news is he
still has the nuclear codes
but twitter facebook instagram shut him
down
that's how over the top it was this was
incited
this was an insurrection that was
incited
by the president of the united states
whether he's
democrat republican independent or some
other party
it doesn't matter it was incited
and it was incited over a period of time
with constant promotion of
baseless conspiracy theories and
fraudulent and false claims of a stolen
election
they exhausted all opportunities in the
court system to overturn the election
so they turned to this he turned
to this now our mission today is
eventually get the football
but i think it would be
impossible to not acknowledge something
that shows such a fundamental flaw chris
in our
current government society civilization
that has many of the things that we have
taken for granted over the years on the
brink right now
yeah well it's it's troubling there's no
other way to say it i mean i'm i'm here
today you heard me before we went on air
i mean
it's it's it's exhausting it's sad
i don't want to even talk about it
because it's so exhausting it hurts you
it hurts me as an american to my core
but
i i mean honestly this person who's been
the president has been doing that
for two years to me so i'm guess i'm
kind of conditioned to it
but still the state of our country where
our where we're at
mike the way it looked yesterday you
know you bring it up yeah the way it
looks as compared oh a bunch of white
protesters with guns and everything like
that
doesn't seem to be nearly you know
matched with the kind of force when the
black lives matter was going on and they
weren't trying to break into
buildings or the or congress or the
government or anything like that
so so many different things to to you
know
be disappointed in and um you know
i think the thing that's that's more
annoying about this than anything is
this wasn't even real
it's there's there's no show us
facts it's disrespectful to hundreds of
judges and other people who have been
true americans
that we're just gonna go no we're not
gonna listen to you
we're gonna do what we want he won the
election i won the election and that's
it and that's where it's just
really uh scary right now and i think
part of the problem is
people sign on to these ideologies
almost like they sign on to a sports
team and
they they they hold it so close and they
never let it go
and they can't be wrong and this is
look the product of a lot of dysfunction
and acrimony within who we are and how
we interact this is where it leads
because it creates an environment where
someone for his own selfish interest and
the selfish interest is very simple
folks
and and i understand that some of you
are still under his spell
and that's okay i get it i understand
that it may take a while to wash that
off of your brain
but this is a guy who fears
that when he leaves the oval office
he inevitably will end up in prison for
things that he
and his family members have done that
have not been fully
investigated and prosecuted because he
enjoys immunity while he's still the
president so he wants to be the
president for as long as he can be
the president so the goal here was
to find a way to steal the thing that he
claims was stolen from him
so he doesn't face prison once he's out
of the oval office so
if you're going to risk chris engaging
in activities
that may set you up for a potential
prison term hey i'm already
potentially going to prison i'll commit
insurrection i'll incite insurrection
against the united states who cares
what's another 10 years
on top of what i'm already facing and
that's the statute
that everyone should read you know when
something like this happens we're like
well what's going to
who's going to be charged who's going to
be arrested and and i hope that they use
every surveillance camera out there and
they find every person who was involved
in yesterday's insurrection
and they charge them and prosecute them
and imprison them to the fullest extent
of the law
including the people who incited it 115
usc section 2383 whoever incites
sets on foot assists or engages in any
rebellion or insurrection against the
authority of the united states
or the laws thereof or gives aid or
comfort thereto
shall be fined under this title or
imprisoned not more than 10 years or
both
and shall be incapable of holding any
office
of these united states period that's the
roadmap
for every district attorney out there
who has jurisdiction over what occurred
how it was planned is there a conspiracy
to commit this insurrection
there's so much for the legal system to
unpack and i hope they do it
because here's here's here's why chris
and then i'll shut up and let you know
okay i'm all right i'm listening this is
good here here's why
the next time we see a jacob blake video
the next time we see a george floyd
video where
justice is dispensed by a police officer
who serves as judge jury and executioner
in the moment
or attempted executioner in the case of
jacob blake
the the argument is the police should
stand down and let the justice system do
its job and when it comes to
black or brown people who are charged
with crimes the justice system always
does its job it never fails to do its
job it does its job
too much so in this case
when there is clear and opening evidence
of an insurrection against our
government
committed by a large group of
predominantly white
terrorists and they didn't get mowed
down
with m16 fire on the steps
of the capital as black or brown
insurrectionists would have been
they lived to see the end of their
insurrection now the justice system
needs to do
what it in undoubtedly would have done
to any of the insurrectionists if they
were of a different skin color
who had managed to somehow survive
yesterday's insurrection well yeah i
mean that i think that's the most
troubling or one of the most troubling
things there's a lot you know first off
yes it's it's a president that's me
first he's never cared about america
in any shape before him away i mean he's
it's everything about him and i know
you're right i don't know
a lot of people got tricked under that
spell it's it's unbelievable i don't
they don't really know facts of
situations you know
i i see that a lot on social media oh
well it's
okay for the left to march in riot but
first of all it's not even apples to
apples what are we talking about
black people people who were supporting
people of color were marching because
have of um unarmed colored people black
people brown people being killed for no
reason
and let me just say it's still going on
it's been
happening the last month there's four or
five more
but we can't keep up there was a reason
to march
there was a real reason this was not a
reason the
infatuation with a guy who's put me
under a spell and lied to me
and all he really cares about is
corporate rich white america not the guy
that was marching yesterday but
yet they think that's the what's going
on or that's
that's you know that's their god and
it's it's very confusing to me there
that's where i'm very
frustrated about that and it just shows
you how weak we are as a country right
now
i mean we can't even protect the
congress building
but for the people who signed on to that
ideology and
and acted on it that's the key you can
believe whatever you want to believe
that that's part of the beauty of being
an american you've got freedom of speech
freedom of thought freedom of everything
no no but this is where like it's
direction but wait insurrection is the
limit
well yeah but wait but one of the limits
but yes that's one of the winners but
they're believing in nothing
factual and they're being led by our
president to say
they think it's factual because he
tweets it and yet
they're trying to compare that and like
yes it really disturbs me
when you look at pictures from a black
lives matter protest and there's a guy
fully armored with shotguns and machine
guns
every yard on every step of the building
and then again a bunch of white people
march on
it and it's it's it was almost like come
in let's take selfies
i honestly wonder if it was an inside
job that's where i'm at like
was there were they in cahoots with some
people here i mean it was just way too
easy that's scary
that's a separate issue yeah that should
be investigated along with the full and
complete investigation of the
insurrection
whether to what extent there were
members of the capitol police who may
have
who may have given aid and comfort they
fall under 115 section 20
383 as well anyone who has that badge
and has that uniform that made it easier
for the insurrectionists to commit
insurrection shall be responsible and
that's why
i hope and i pray that the justice
system
doesn't just say well we just need to
close the book on this and move on
no justice should be dispensed without
passion or prejudice
to those who have violated the laws of
our country
or those laws become meaningless
and that is what's always waiting for
black and brown individuals who survive
the police interaction
there isn't a well you know this has
gone on far enough we're just going to
let it go no there's a prosecution
there's an incarceration
because you god forbid had marijuana in
your car
or committed some other offense that's
trivial in comparison to trying to
overthrow the government the united
states and there's been a lot of terms
thrown around chris
i want to make sure everybody
understands what these terms mean
because when you
understand the definition of the terms
you realize
that these things are happening and that
our president is inciting them
sedition conduct or speech inciting
people to rebel against the authority of
a
state or monarch the president's guilty
of sedition
he's incited people to rebel and they
did we know that he incited them because
it worked
we saw what he said yesterday outside
the capitol
before the insurrection happened he
incited it rudy giuliani incited with
the phrase trial by combat donald trump
jr incited it we're going to come get
you
treason the crime of betraying one's
country especially by attempting to kill
the sovereign or overthrow the
government
the actions yesterday were treasonous
one of the penalties for treason is
death
insurrection a violent uprising against
an authority or government it clearly
was an insurrection it clearly was
incited by the president it does not
take
a law degree to see what happened
yesterday and to understand how our laws
apply and if they do not apply swiftly
and decisively
those laws are meaningless chris yeah
yeah they are you're right i you know
i i don't even know what to say i really
don't even know what to say anymore mike
i really don't
i'm like i'm so there's so much i want
to say i don't want to get fired today
here on tv
i'm truly flabbergasted i don't want you
to get [ __ ] i know i know you don't i
know you don't love me but you kind of
like me and doing the show with me so
yeah i know and that's where i'm just
i'm trying not to go crazy here and
really pour my emotions out
um but i'm very frustrated by it and
yeah
i just feel like there's a lot of me me
me
and no america and i don't really know
what's going on in our world right now
but i'm disappointed
and um i'm glad we got football at least
to take my mind off this damn subject
and we'll eventually get to i know but
it's our obligation
it is to our audience to our country and
to ourselves to not ignore this and just
come on the air and be all bright and
cheery
and and promote super wild card weekend
we'll get to that in time
but these are real issues that speak to
the heart of who we are
what we are and what we will be as a
nation and as long as it's called the
national football league
serious affairs of our nation are
relevant to the national football league
nfl players spoke out yesterday via
twitter let's take a look at some of the
things that
guys had to say alan robinson today was
acts of terrorism and should be treated
as such
amen alan robinson and that's exactly
what i've been saying
devonte adams same people that didn't
want us kneeling
never mind face palm emoji exactly and
we'll we'll have time to talk about the
between colin kaepernick and actual
insurrection richard sherman there are
certain things my brain could never
imagine and one of the black people
storming a government building and
taking things without deadly
consequences but that's
just my brain richard that's my brain
too we disagree on some things we agree
on many
we agree on that if it was black or
brown insurrectionist
most if not all of them would be dead
today
robert griffin iii the difference in the
treatment between races in america is on
full display it absolutely is and
this is the thing that hurts the black
and brown american
as much as seeing no doubt their
community member being killed when you
see a white person
who ends up being helped down the steps
by a capitol police officer instead of
thrown down the steps
violently that's the difference stop
saying stick to football like that's our
only purpose on this earth said justin
jefferson
shut up with that crowd to speak on
whatever we feel no matter the situation
i think we've all got to the point where
anyone who says stick to football or
stick to sports
is saying we don't want you to say
something that disagrees with what we
believe yeah that's all it is
last one from dez bryant let's keep it
real for a moment i'm just wondering
where the tasers and tear gas
like they do black people when they are
peacefully protesting just a thought not
that i promote violence and chaos but
black people could never
come out of that alive i'm hoping real
changes can happen for the future of
this country because it's an ugly mess
right now and that is the fundamental
point because
life goes on and
the next video of a black person
being shot during a police interaction
is going to have much different meaning
the next video
of tanks rolling down the street to
disrupt a peaceful protest
of tear gas being used to clear out
lafayette square
so someone can have a photo op with a
bible he's holding upside down
that's going to have a far different
context because insurrection is stormed
the capital
and were not mowed down in a hail of
gunfire
that contrast is stunning and frankly
chris i'm surprised the reaction from
the sports world
yeah players and the like hasn't been
strong i think as it sinks in it will be
stronger
and i wrote last night at pft an item
calling on owners
and commissioners to join in this
because this is one of the worst things
we have inflicted upon ourselves i know
911 was worse
but that was from outside yesterday was
the worst
day we've had as a country since the
civil war because we inflicted it
on ourselves yeah well you mean radical
white terrorism has become the number
one issue in our country it's it's a
white crazy americans that act in a
terrorist way is the number one threat
it's the people i'm scared of more than
anything
and yesterday was the ultimate show
of white privilege if anybody didn't
want to believe in white privilege
yesterday proved it i don't know what
else there is to be said about it mike
and to me
that's where i'm troubled by this more
than anything when i just look at online
at your twit some of your tweets and the
comments underneath
that's where i i am very angered about
the person who continues to try to argue
that yesterday was comparable to the
black lives matter
mostly peaceful protest we also have
information of a lot
of white terrorists going there and
burning
things on fire to make the black people
look like they were doing that
we know that that's in fbi reports and
everything we know
we know we've seen the trucks with trump
flags
and that inciting that kind of stuff at
the black lives matter thing but
still people trying to compare the
destruction of yesterday
to that is what still really bothers me
and it shows me that there's a group of
people out there that really still have
no clue
they don't get it they're totally void
of facts of the infam
information because they're following
it's quite honestly
the most narcissistic bad person i've
ever seen in my life on twitter
and just taking his word for it and that
to me is what
bothers me more than anything mike right
now is that trying to make that apples
to apples comparison where
like you said we have videos and we
still
have more stories here recently yeah we
don't have the videos but of unarmed
black people
being shot and killed how about the
black teenager
who you know got accused of stealing the
phone he got that on video the woman
wouldn't let him go she calls the cops
it's all over our country right now
people don't want to admit that and want
to fight that
and some of them want to let yesterday
like compare that and that's where i'm
very frustrated with that narrative
right now to think that's apples to
apples is crazy
i agree with you completely and today is
a day where we will have media
availability from
coaches and players as we get closer to
the playoff weekend most of the teams
have disbanded for the year 18 are done
but 14 are still going in 12 play this
weekend and
here's hoping that those opportunities
to speak to reporters
include some raw and some real feelings
about what we saw yesterday
and here's hoping that quickly and
decisively
the justice system moves to rectify what
occurred
yesterday the good news is last night
congress
went back into session and they stayed
there until 2 30 in the morning when
they completed their work of certifying
the election
so it's over and it's done on january 20
whether anyone likes it or not and there
have been presidential outcomes that
i've liked
and that i haven't liked but at the end
of the day we have to accept them and
move on as a country
january 20 joe biden will be the
president
between now and then hopefully nothing
happens like what happened yesterday
hopefully what happened yesterday
is the thing that will wake people up to
understand that there are limits
to how far we can go and that we must be
willing
to call an insurrection exactly what it
is
an insurrection that should be met on
the other side
with significant criminal sanctions for
everyone involved
including the man who incited it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports